(soft music)
- I'm Kelly Bathe, I have
two mixed-race children,
half-Irish and half Black.
- My name is Kathy Weiss, and
I have a 34-year old daughter
and a 27-year old son,
Jeremy, who is adopted.
- My name is Shelly Patrick,
and I'm the mother of two sons.
They're my biological children.
- My name is Frank Cayetti,
and I have two children.
A 6 and a half year old
daughter named Lucy,
and a 3 and a half year old
adopted son named Joseph.
- My husband and I started
dating when we were in
our thirties, and we never
really thought about the fact
that we were a mixed-race
couple until we decided
to have children.
My kids were gonna face
situations that I just didn't know
how to navigate because I
had never faced them myself.
I remember just sobbing,
and my husband taking me
in his arms, and telling me
that it's not my job to teach
my son to be a black
man, that it's his job.
That it's my job to teach my
kids respect, and kindness
just like every other mother
in the world, regardless
of what color my skin is.
- We tried to have another child.
There were issues with me
that was not gonna enable us
to have another biological child.
Social workers actually came
out with a policy against
transracial adoptions.
There was a strong belief
that white families couldn't
provide what black children
needed for their own identity.
We did not live the black
experience in America and
how do we provide him some
connection to what the world
sees him as, even if his
personal experience is slightly
different than that?
- We wanted to adopt for many reasons.
My wife was very much compelled,
she has an adopted brother
and she worked at a nonprofit
that worked with a lot of
former foster youths.
We talked about trying to
have a biological child first,
and then the next thing we
were interested in doing is
adopting.
I was talking to a woman I
met at a theater opening.
She's African-American, the
subject of my kids came up
because I love talking about them.
She asked, point-blank, which
is a really good question:
are you going to allow some
influence in his life from
other African-American people?
I was kind of stumped for
a second and then realized
I absolutely have to.
- I was only about 20 when I had Jason.
I don't know if it was my
immaturity, but I didn't really
look at my kids as
black, or white, or half,
I just looked at them as my children.
When I was going through my
divorce, I'm seeing a therapist
at the time, she pointed
out how important it was
for the children to have
regular time with their father
and his side of the
family, so that they could
learn the nonverbal
communication skills of
the black culture.
So that was something I
was always mindful of and
made sure that that happened.
- Consultation is just an admission that
you don't know everything.
It doesn't make me feel weird
at all-- it makes me a little
sad to think that he's going
to have some experiences
that I can't entirely relate to.
- My daughters hair was
definitely a learning experience.
I have a niece who also
has a mixed-race daughter.
She actually has given
me so much information.
YouTube tutorials, Pinterest,
learning what co washing is,
just making her realize
how precious and amazing
her hair is.
- I don't think we would
have thought about moving
out of Philadelphia for a minute.
Jeremy wouldn't feel
out of place growing up,
he would see other people
that looked liked him,
family friends and personal
friends, and teachers.
You know, we were always
aware of that strong presence
in his life.
He would have the resources,
he would go somewhere
if he needed to figure things out.
- MY husband has had to teach me.
I have taken on his thoughts
on this, that you would
rather know who's a racist
because now you know
who to stay away from.
It's the ones who aren't
saying it, but are thinking it
are the ones that are the real issues.
- When Jeremy was a very
young child, strangers would
come up to us and say,
"Oh, he's gonna be a
great ball player isn't he?"
at some point I would say,
why, because he's black?
At other points, I just
got fed up with it and said
no, he's actually gonna
be a brain surgeon.
It is stunning to me what
comes out of people's mouths
and I am still not quiet about it.
- I recall this one time I
went to look at a townhouse.
When I went into view it
with the realtor, a person
who lived there came in
and he was like, saying
"Oh this is a great complex,
and you'll like living
here, and we don't have
any" and he used the n-word,
"that live here."
I'm gonna get choked up.
And I said, well I will
not be renting here because
I have two half-black
children, and it would make
me nervous to have them
here with somebody that
thinks that way.
Some white people just let
it roll off, but when you
have children, you
don't just let it slide.
- You teach your kids tact,
and you teach your kids
that ignorance is
everywhere, and unfortunately
I'm not gonna be able to
save them from everything.
- It has been very important
for me to talk to Jeremy.
He had one incident where
somebody said something
to him, I think when
he was around 11 or 12,
and he never told us, and
dealt with it probably
by talking to his friends.
I felt like I had failed
him, his friends maybe
were a better resource.
I felt like, sheesh, why can't
he talk to me about this?
- You have to teach, and you
have to talk to your kids
about police brutality.
You have to talk to your
kids about racist undertones.
I would rather have
the conversation before
anybody else has it with her, so that she
understands where we stand.
- The interesting thing
that I think I've observed
about race, is I have a privilege to not
be cognizant of it and others do not.
I have to be empathetic
to my son in that regard.
The issues that Joseph
may face terrifies me;
someday I'm gonna have to have
a real tough conversation,
now I just want him to be
the happiest 3 and a half
year old kid out there.
- My husband, being a
black parent, he had talks
with them, but a few
times, when they came home
and told me they had been
called a racial name,
it really upset me, but
then when they told me
how they handled it, I
was so proud of them.
I knew that they were equipped
and strong to handle it.
- Jeremy definitely had identity issues,
I don't think it was all smooth sailing
and everything's been "Leave
it to Beaver" nice for him.
He had to figure out what it meant
to be a black man in
America with a white family
and a Jewish background,
because he walks into
a room and the narrative is written.
He's always struggling
with his own definition
against a public definition is of him.
- So my hope for the future
is, you know, we start
to evolve as a nation.
- When you see children playing together,
they may be cognizant of the difference
in the way that they
look, but I don't think
there's any preconceived
notion, I think that
racism is a learned behavior.
- My hope for my children
is that they grow up
and they learn to be kind, and
they learn to be respectful.
- Jeremy's trying to make it
in the world of music right now
I think he has great talent,
but I'm a party of one
with a little bit of bias.
- I just want them to feel
safe and feel loved, and
secure in who they are.
- I hope that my children
are successful, and enjoy
their lives as they have fun.